my first job out of college was working
at a place similar to the one that's
portrayed in the movie and the the
innate character encompasses all of the
feelings and fears that I had during my
first couple months working there
looking at myself who I was at that time
it was it was an an unhealthy way to
view the situation I thought that I was
going in there to help people and to
change people and make their lives
better when in reality by the end of it
I had learned more about myself and
grown more myself than I ever had before
so that's that's where the story
blossoms from I was developing the the
screenplay with Asher Goldstein and
Maren Olsen who are in the house they
they helped I was I was getting notes
from them throughout the course of the
second rewrite of the script over the
course of about three months or so
leading up to the the nickel submission
and I bit her because a friend told me
about it I didn't know that much about
it and I submitted and forgot about it
and at the time of the announce that
they announced the finalists and that
started happening I'd completely
forgotten about it and I was also on the
verge literally of giving up on this
script and this story and it was it was
a time that I had received quite a bit
of rejections which is just a part of
every process of any any um but you know
it was at the point where I was just
like alright I gotta move on to
something else and that's that's when I
got those first those first nods which
word that you thought you made it to the
quarterfinals I was like the first thing
and that was enough I was like okay then
well there's something there's something
here and it was
such a boost of encouragement short-term
12 was a short film first
and you premiered that and that was in
Sundance as well did that help you get
get it to the future future length the
short film basically what happened and
when we won the nickel fellowship that
allowed me that that fellowship allowed
me to survive that year and write
another screenplay and I actually saved
up that money that they gave me and used
it to make my first feature called I am
NOT a hipster which was my script that I
wrote during my fellowship year that was
extremely helpful I think and taking the
next step was short terms I had done
films that were not for as many days in
someone's skin that's going through such
a hard period of time and I've and it
would take you know I'd film something
for two weeks and it would take me three
months of therapy to get it out of it
because you can't help but start
bringing up your own things and next
thing you know you've created these
problems in yourself that you don't know
how to deal with a big part of it was
actually being on the floor and and
shadowing a woman who's in the field and
you can't help but just feel how much
strength it takes to get through one day
on the floor with those kids let alone
doing it for a week or a year or 17
years and I think the woman I think she
actually had been in at 23 years by the
time that I had met her and so that was
one my questions how how do you how do
you stay so strong how do you stay so
clear her eyes are so clear and she said
you let go and it was as if it was you
know something that had taken her a
really long time to understand but now
it's just her mantra which is you you're
there you're focused you give it
everything that you have and then you go
home and you don't fight anymore you
release you take a bubble bath you knit
you watch South Park which is my
personal choice and you know you do
those things and you forget about it and
you have to save a little bit for
yourself and if you don't that
eventually and it might not happen in
the first week but eventually you'll
crack and then you're of no use to
really anybody there are a few scenes
that I mean I don't know that kills the
magic to say that just didn't make it in
the movie but that always happens but I
am so happy that those scenes were shot
because they're not necessary for the
film but they were necessary for me to
inform me of other sides of Greece that
I was able to explore and then that
brought me back to who she was again
it's interesting as you go through that
very strange creative process of making
a film that you don't know how to
schedule anything when it comes like
I've got this big thing and we're gonna
shoot out of order and then we're gonna
these are the least important maybe but
these are also important and then and
it's magic and that's the thing that was
so interesting is you release yourself
to the process and you go for it and we
were all very loving and very patient
and I feel like destined with this film
being so much about love and and parent
and child and the human connection I
feel so lucky to have worked with this
person and to know this person to know
these people I think it's very brave to
write a really selfless character I
think like high-stakes drama usually
involves a lot of selfishness and people
really wanting things from each other
coveting things and I was so blown away
when I read the script for the first
time that that Destin had just written
such a realistically selfless loving
caring patient understanding supportive
person and I was so moved by it in a way
- there's that there's a thing where I
think as the film goes on you you might
start thinking like well gosh is this
guy just a doormat or something like
what and then there's this lovely reveal
in the last act or you see where he
comes from and that's why I think it's
so easy for him to take care of the kids
all day and then go home and continue to
take care of someone that he'll also
loves very deeply all night and they do
it all over again the next day if I'm
not mistaken you're the only actor who
was in the short film of short-term 12
so you came back did you play Marcus in
the in the short as well
I played mark in the short and in the
other version I played mark is which is
basically an evolution of the grown-up
part is it okay I felt like it's been
five years between this short and this
and I felt like I was they say in five
years all your atoms like you're
constantly gaining and losing atoms all
right so every five years you have a new
set of like a full new set of atoms so
basically you're a new person and that's
how I felt I felt like I did so much
more life experience and was a lot more
comfortable and set at that time so I
felt like a new person so I felt Marcus
should probably be a new person you did
two songs on the film including the song
over the end credits after-party three
if you count a vicious which was playing
when I did the bloody massacres
mm-hmm-hmm when you see me the script
I saw the original rat and I was like
what the hell is going on here but you
know what was what was crazy about it is
his template was perfect I actually told
him the other night like we should form
a band and you write all the templates
and then I'll come back and just spice
it up dirty it up a little bit because
that's basically what we did like hear
the bear rap and I really liked the flow
in the way it was going and it was
telling a story accurately but it just
didn't seem to it didn't feel real like
for someone who's been rapping so long
and I actually I actually wrapped so I
was just like I I'll go back in and then
and then that was the final product it
was his template my sprinkles yeah
sprinkles sprinkles okay